My question was uh it's in Luke. Jesus
was talking to uh I'm not I don't
remember exactly to whom he was talking
but he said this generation will be held
responsible for the blood of all
prophets. Oh yeah. Yes. That's that's in
Luke 11. Luke 11:50-51. But it's also
found in Matthew 23.
Yes. Yes. And let me show you. Let me
answer that question first. Let's break
down the implication. Let's go to the
Mian version. Let's go to Matthew 23.
When you get to Matthew 23, I want you
to read. Start. Just read 32 and 33.
Matthew 23 32 and 33. Guys, he's asking
me a question. Pay attention to the
question. Jesus says, Jesus says to the
generation of Jews, all the wickedness
and evil and unrighteous killing, all
the murders have taken place from the
beginning will fall on this generation,
fall on you. Why? Why? the sins of the
past will fall on them. Now, you guys
ready for meat? You're going to get meat
now, brother. It's a really deep. If you
guys are ready, we're going to unpack
this. Let's go to Matthew
23:32-33. And read it for me, brother,
when you get there. Perfect. Fill up
then the measure of your father's guilt.
Serpents, brood of vipers. How can you
escape the condemnation of hell? Okay. I
don't want anyone to forget what you
read. He called them serpents, brood of
vipers.
these religious Jews, Jewish leaders,
pay attention. He said to the Jewish
leaders, "Your serpents brought a
vipers." We're going to come back to
that. Just keep that in mind. But I want
you to read 32. It said, "Fill up the
full measure of sin." Number one, the
Bible talks about a limit of how much
sin a nation will commit before God then
turns in wrath against that nation. For
example, America has a limit of sin.
Each generation of Americans, if they
continue in sin, they keep filling up
the sins of the generation before until
reach the breaking point and they leave
God no choice but not to destroy it. You
with me there? Yes. Let me show you that
from what God says to Abraham. God tells
Abraham, "Only in the fourth generation,
400 years from now, will your
descendants come back to this land of
Canaan and inherit it." So, why is God
going to wait 400 years before he gives
them the land? Go to Genesis 15:16.
Here's the
answer. Genesis 15:16.
But in the fourth generation, they shall
return here, for the iniquity of the
Amorites is not yet complete. Did you
guys catch it? God says to Abraham, "The
reason why it's going to take four
generations from now, which is 400
years, because he says 400 years from
now, before your descendants return to
take the land, because the full measure
of the sin of the Arammites has not been
complete." Did you catch it? Mhm. That
means God is going to wait until they
reach the fullness of their sin. How
much he'll accept before he now turns to
destroy
them. So, you get that point before I
unpack it. Absolutely. So each
generation commits sins and if they
continue in the footsteps of the
generation before where they commit the
sins of the generation before then God's
patience runs out. Then you reach a
point says God God says I'm done with
you. Now it's time for destruction
because I put up with you and I have
given you signs and wonders to repent
but you keep defying me. Now you're at a
point of no return. It's over. So now
let's go to another example. 1
Thessalonians 2 14-
16. 1 Thessalonians 2 14-
16. Read that for me. Guys, pay
attention to this because it's a lot of
meat. Now
for you, brethren, became imitators of
the churches of God which are in Judea
in Christ Jesus. For you also suffered
the same things from your own
countrymen, just as they did from the
Judeans, who killed both the Lord Jesus
and their own prophets, and have
persecuted us. And they do and they do
not please God, and are contrary to all
men, forbidding us to speak to the
Gentiles that they might be saved, so as
always to fill up the measure of their
sins. Sounds familiar. Yes. That's what
Jesus said to the Jews, right? Mhm. fill
up the full measure of your sins. So
when they do, what does Paul say will
happen to them? Finish the last line.
But wrath has come upon them to the
uttermost. You see, Jesus and Paul
confirm the Jews who persecuted Jesus
and us, they're going to now fill up the
full measure of sin and then God's wrath
will fall. What was the sign that they
reached the breaking point and God was
done with Jerusalem and now his wrath
was poured out. What was the sign? Do
you remember? God was done with them
because he destroyed the temple in
Jerusalem. just like Jesus
said would happen. Now start instead of
35 read 34 to 39.
Okay. Therefore indeed I send you
prophets, wise men and scribes. Some of
them you will kill and crucify and some
of them you will scourge in your
synagogues and persecute from city to
city that on you may come all the
righteous blood shed on the earth from
the blood of righteous Abel to the blood
of Zachariah. And we'll come back to
that in a minute. We're going to come
back to that. Keep reading. Son of Bar
Bariah. Yeah. Zechariah, son of Bariah,
whom you slew. Whom you murdered between
the temple and the By the way, those
Jews did not murder him because that
murder took place hundreds of years
earlier. But he's saying you slew him.
Keep that in mind. We're going to come
back to that, but keep reading. Okay.
Assuredly I say to you, all the all
these things will come up upon this
generation.
Oh Jerusalem, Jerusalem, the one who
kills the prophets and stones those who
are sent to her. How often I wanted to
gather your children together as a hen
gathers her chicks under her wig, sorry,
under her wings, but you were not
willing. See, your house is left to to
you desolate. For I say to you, you
shall see me no more till you say,
"Blessed is he who comes in the name of
the Lord." So what will happen? because
they didn't recognize Jesus and because
they're going to kill all those that
Jesus sends them, the prophets and wise
men, what will happen? What did he say
is going to happen in Jerusalem? Their
house will be left desolate and their
house is what? Uh is Jerusalem? Yes. And
what's in Jerusalem though? The temple.
Yes. That's why in Matthew 24, do you
think it's a coincidence the next
chapter he talks about destruction of
the temple in Jerusalem? No. Okay. So,
are you getting it? Yeah. What's the
sign that Israel had reached the climax
of how much sin God would accept and
it's over for them? What did God do to
show it's done? The destruction of the
temple. Ah, that's what Paul was saying.
Wrath is going to come upon them. And
it's not just wrath because they
rejected Jesus because Paul said they
persecuted us. And Jesus said in Matthew
23:34, even after killing me, I'm going
to send you prophets and wise men. Some
you'll kill, some you'll throw out. And
you'll do that so you can reach the
limit. So the limit of sin wasn't simply
killing Jesus. The the the limit of sin
was reached after killing Jesus. Then
they persecuted and killed his inspired
emissaries.
Wow. Okay. Amazing. Did you catch it
now? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So that took
another 40 years. Okay. Now what's the
point? Do you remember Matthew 23:32?
Read it one more time.
32. same chap cuz let's put it all
together.
Philillip then the measure of your
father's guilt. Okay, you see your
father started the sin but you're going
to be the generation that now reaches
the climax.
There's only a certain amount of sin I
will
tolerate. That began with your fathers
long ago, but now you're that generation
that now reaches the limit and it's
over.
Incredible. Okay, you catching it now?
But now this is where it's going to come
to. Matthew 23:33. Read Matthew 23:33.
Serpents, brood of vipers. How can you
escape the condemnation of hell? Okay,
notice you are serpents. You are the
brood of vipers. Your fathers are vipers
are snakes. Don't forget that image. And
you are snakes. You're serpents. because
he says all the sins beginning with your
first
father and ending with you, right?
You'll be punished for it. Why? Because
instead of repenting, you continued in
their footstep. It's like remember what
God said to Abraham about the
Canaanites, the Amorites. Mhm. 400 years
from now, they're going to reach a a
full measure of sin that started 400
years earlier. 400 years of sin that I
tolerated and it's going to fall on that
generation. It's over. I'm going to
destroy the land and throw them
out. So what God is saying is if you
continue in the pattern of sin started
by your ancestors, then you share in
their
guilt, but you can be freed from that
guilt. If you turn away, repent, and now
you'll be united to Christ, so you don't
suffer any wrath for continuing the sin
started by the generation before
you. You with me so far? Yeah. Yeah.
It's perfect. It's It makes perfect
sense. Oh, but it's going to get even
more shocking because notice it says,
"One of the sins committed by your
father is the murder of Abel." Now, go
back to Matthew 23. Read 35-36.
That on you may come all the righteous
blood shed on the earth. From the blood
of righteous Abel to the blood of
Zachariah, son of Baraka, whom you
murdered between the temple and the
altar.
So I Yeah, go ahead. Read that. Read 36.
Assuredly I say to you, all these things
will come upon this generation. So
notice what he said. Fill up the full
measure of the sin of your fathers. So
all those sins will fall on this
generation, but one of their fathers
murdered Abel.
Did you catch it? Matthew 23:35. Yeah.
Yeah. Hold on. I don't think you caught
it. Who murdered Abel?
Jesus is in reality it's their fathers.
Then he says one of your fathers
murdered Abel and you're going to share
in that guilt. Who murdered Abel?
Cain. Well, you're guessing. Are you
sure you don't? Come on. Who murdered
Abel? Dude, Kane. Okay. Cain. But wait,
Cain is not their physical father.
Cain's line was destroyed in the flood.
[Music]
Why is he saying your father? Because
you missed verse 33. Serpents brood of
vipers because they are sons of the
serpent Satan. So Cain is the seed of
the serpent in Genesis 3 where God said
to the serpent, I will put hatred
between you serpent and the woman
between your seed and her seed. So the
seed of the serpent are the spiritual
sons of the devil starting with his
first son Cain. So he's saying you Jews,
your father's the devil. Therefore your
spiritual father is Cain, not Abraham.
Oh,
did you catch it now? Yeah. Wow. Why do
you think he lists Cain as one of their
fathers? Because he says, "You're
serpents." But if you're a serpent, that
means you're the seed of the serpent.
Right. Yeah. But what serpent? Genesis
3:15, God says to the serpent, "I will
put hatred between you, the serpent, and
the woman. Your seed will be at war with
her seed." Cain, the seed of the
serpent, was at war with the seed of the
woman, Abel. So the seed of the serpent
killed the seed of the woman Abel. And
that's the pattern ever since.
Wow. Did you catch what Jesus just did?
Yes. So he's saying you Jews, though
ethnically you are sons of Abraham,
Abraham's not truly your father. You are
truly the sons of the serpent. You are
the serpents brood of vipers. So that
your true ancestor is Cain, not Abraham.
Go to John 8
39-44. You caught it? Yeah. Now it all
makes sense, isn't it, right? Yeah. It's
amazing. John 8:39-44.
Okay. And they answered and said to him,
"Abraham is our father." Jesus said to
them, "If you were Abraham's children,
you would do the works of Abraham. But
now you seek to kill to kill me, a man
who has told you the truth which I heard
from God. Abraham did not do this. You
do the deeds of your father. Then they
said to him, "We were not born of
fornication. We have one father, God."
Jesus said to them, "If God were your
father, you would have loved me. For I
proceeded forth and came from God, nor
have I come of myself, but he sent me.
Why did you not understand my speech?
because you are not able to listen to my
word. You are of your father, the devil.
Uh oh. Wait, wait, wait. The Jews just
said Abraham's their father. And Jesus
said, "Well, if Abraham was your father,
you'd act like him." But you're not.
You're trying to murder me. You know
why? Cuz your father is the devil.
Ethnic Jews and their father is the
devil. So they belong to who? Abraham or
Cain? Cain. Spiritually, not physically.
So what you're learning here, here's
what you're learning. True lineage is
spiritual, not physical.
True paternity is spiritual, not
physical. Because you can be a physical
Jew, but your true father is the devil
and your ancestors came spiritually. Or
you can be a gentile, but your true
father is God and you are the seed of
Abraham spiritually. That's what
Galatians 3:26-29 says, right? Yeah.
Wow. You see, so what did he say? Who's
your father? The devil. Now finish it.
and the desire and the desires of your
father you want to do. He was a murderer
from the beginning and does not stand in
the truth because there is no truth in
him. When he speaks a lie, he speaks
from his own resources for he is a liar
and the father of it. Okay, now did you
catch it? The true murderer, the first
murder wasn't Cain. It was the devil.
Because the devil murdered Adam and Eve
by causing them to sin. He is the first
murderer. So it's not surprising that
his seed Cain ended up murdering like
his father.
You caught it? Yeah. Who was the
murderer from the beginning? He said the
devil, right? Mhm. But how did the devil
murder? He didn't murder anyone
physically. He murdered them spiritually
by causing them to sin. So is it a
surprise that Cain, who is his son,
ended up murdering like the devil did?
No. Because he's like his father, the
devil. Right. And then what does the
devil do? Lie. Right.
Yeah. Is it a coincidence that when God
asked Cain, "Where's your brother?" He
goes, "How should I know? Am I my
brother's keeper?" So, the two traits of
the devil, lying and murdering, you see
it in Cain's life. He murdered and he
lied.
Wow. Right. Yeah. And what did Jesus say
about the devil? He's the father of
lies. He's a murderer and a liar. And
when he lies, he speaks his native
tongue because there's no truth in him.
What did Cain do? Murder and lie the
very fruits of his father, the serpent,
the devil.
Oh, now go to the final passage. 1 John
3:12.
1 John 3:12. See how much meat is in
this book.
It's amazing. This book is supernatural
for those who have eyes of senior ears
to hear. There's no doubt this book is
of God and God is real. I mean, you got
to be blind not to see it. But now, 1
John 3:12.
Just want to say I'm ashamed of reading
the Bible and not taking the time to
actually understand what every verses
mean. Exactly. It's to our shame because
there's meat there. That's why people
don't appreciate the Bible because they
don't go deep.
Mhm. And they think it's just No, no,
no. It is supernatural. It's going to
make you if you plunge the depths of it,
there won't be a day that you won't be
going, "Wow, wow,
wow." Right? Until Jesus takes you. But
now read 1 John 3:12.
Not as Cain who was the wicked one and
murdered his brother. So wait, the Cain
belonged to who?
The wicked one. So the Cain who was of
the wicked one. Mhm. You see it right?
Yeah. Don't be like Cain who is of the
wicked one who murdered his brother.
Because you are children of God. You
love one another. You don't hate one
another and desire to kill one
another. Okay. So now, who was the first
son of the serpent? Because remember
Jesus said, because that's Jesus talking
to Adam and Eve. You serpent, I'll put
hatred between you and the woman that
you never agree with one another. You'll
be at war with one another. And there's
going to be hatred between your seed and
her seed. So who was the first seed of
the serpent? Cain. Cain was the devil's
firstborn son.
You caught it? Yeah. Yeah. The first son
of the devil was Cain. And everyone, Jew
or Gentile, who follows in the footsteps
of Cain has Cain as their ancestor, even
if he's a Jew, because the devil is
their father. Now, you understand why
also the Lord Jesus made sure there'd be
hatred between the serpent and the
woman.
I heard you once talk about this and I
ne I never really understood it. I know
you took it in a way and said that it's
the reason why women follow men who
treat them badly. That was the
punishment on the woman that says you
want to hear that again, don't you
little sinner. But no, before we get to
Genesis 3:16, what I'm saying, why did
he put hatred between the serpent and
the woman, not the woman and Adam? See,
you just turned Adam into a devil. Why
you My bad. My bad. Why the hatred? Why?
Because the reason why guys don't see
this. You guys didn't see this. Why do
you think the Lord Jesus, because that
was Jesus who appeared on behalf of the
Godhead along with the Holy Spirit to
refresh them? Why do you think the Lord
Jesus said, "I'm going to put hatred
between you and the woman." Anyone
figure out why? Think about it. This
will show you the love of Jesus for his
creation, especially the love of Jesus
and protection of
women. Why do you think he said
that? Anyone have an idea? Do you have
an idea, brother? My guess would be
because Jesus would come from the line
of the woman. That's part of it. in
order to make sure that the serpent
would never tempt the woman to sin
against him. This was his way of
protecting her, assuming the role of
Adam because Adam failed to protect her.
So now he's protecting her. Instead of
you and the serpent getting along, I'll
make sure you never get along so he
never does to you what he just did. Ah,
okay. You guys caught
it. Because when you hate someone, are
you going to work with that someone? No.
So that's his way of protecting her.
Okay. Okay. Never again will you be
tempted by the serpent because I'm going
to make sure I protect you from his
snares and temptation. Something Adam
should have done but he failed. So I'm
going to step in and assume the role
that Adam should have assumed but he
failed you. But I won't.
Wow. You see
it? You you guys caught it right?
Because if they hate each other, they're
not going to work with each other. Mhm.
But remember, prior to that moment,
they're having conversations. Never
again. You and her will be at war so
that you never get under her good graces
to dup her into doing what you want her
to do. Cuz this is what my way of
protecting her from you. She's going to
despise you.
Right? So to wrap it up, why did Jesus
say all the sins? Because the Bible is
quite clear. Each generation, if they
continue in the pattern of the
generation before, will share either in
the guilt or the blessing of the
generation that came before it. In other
words, if you're a Canaanite and you
continue the practices of your parents,
if you continue that pattern, then
you're continuing the sins of the of the
generation that came before you. And if
you keep repeating that pattern
generation after generation, there's so
much sin that God will tolerate. So much
abomination that God will tolerate, so
much murder that God will tolerate, will
tolerate, so much incest that God will
tolerate. And he says, until he says,
"Enough. You're like gangarine, cancer
that spread too far. I have to cut it
off in order to save the rest of the
body."
So what was God telling the Jews there?
You are that generation that started
with Cain that's not going to reach the
full limit and I'm done with you. Now,
that doesn't mean all the Jews are the
sons of Cain. No, all the Jews that
reject the f reject following Jesus are
of Cain because they belong to the
devil. But if you're a Jew who follows
Jesus, you're no longer the seed of the
serpent. You're the seed of the woman,
the seed of Abraham, the seed of God,
and you belong to Christ. After all,
Jesus's Jewish followers, weren't they
all Jews?
Yeah. Jesus's mother, wasn't she Jewish?
Mhm. They were not of the seed of Cain.
They were the seed of Abraham, the seed
of the woman, the seed of God, because
they turned to Jesus, thereby being cut
off from belonging to the serpent.
There you go. I hope that answered your
question.